she was literally a little bit longer
than my hand when she was blind and they
told us that she wouldn't make it Rachel
inspires so many people inadvertently I
haven't granted what are you guys
yelling at him because I was telling him
what is wrong with you she would just
simply not even get out of bed you're
going along all day saying what could I
do wrong with it I do wrong it's
contributing to the bifurcation of
education in this country but at the
same time I'm not gonna short shrift my
kid New York City is home to some of the
world's worst public schools for
children with special needs that
warehouse their students in chaotic and
unsupportive environments today a
growing number of affluent families are
successfully suing the city on the
grounds that these schools are so bad
taxpayers need to foot the bill to send
their children to elite private
institutions what if the city were to
provide all families with school choice
so that even learning disabled kids from
poor homes could get an excellent
education the status quo is the source
of enormous inequities upper middle
class parents are able to work the
system to get the very best for their
kids but who can blame them
stop laughing they threw tally who asked
that we change her name for this story
to protect the privacy of her family is
a single mother of three boys who lives
in Bay Ridge Brooklyn when he was in the
third grade her oldest son was diagnosed
with dyslexia attention deficit disorder
and severe anxiety from second to third
grade he was vomiting every single
morning before he was going to school
the city of New York recommended that
she send him to a public school that
specializes in serving children with
disabilities so she took a tour and was
horrified you could see the students in
the back of the classroom talking
disrupting one teacher comes out and
started screaming in the hallway it
quiet be quiet so it was it was very
chaotic although she couldn't afford the
tuition she enrolled him in one of
Brooklyn's premier private schools for
children with learning disabilities he
walked in the screen because oh my gosh
mom this is learning disability heaven
and he was so happy everyone was so
nurturing I knew they took care of my
baby as a way to cover the annual
tuition of about $45,000 she sued the
city on the grounds that it had failed
to provide him with an appropriate
public option as required under the 1975
individuals with Disabilities Education
Act when it turned out that her second
son also had learning disabilities rich
Holly once again sued the city to cover
a private school tuition and now she's
about to do it again for her youngest
and this is a growing practice the
amount the city spends annually on
private school tuition has more than
doubled in the last six years to two
hundred and forty four million dollars
and the cost for each student rose to
fifty five thousand dollars last year
and it's likely to keep going up she
would just simply not even get out of
bed David Bernstein is a publishing
executive who lives on Manhattan's Upper
East Side when his daughter started
experiencing crippling anxiety at the
age of 12 he and his ex-wife toured some
of the special education programs within
the public system
and you visit these places and it
literally is a warehouse there are
places where they send kids who are no
longer on an academic track and they're
not even really on a therapeutic track
so they sued now his daughter attends a
boarding school in Connecticut for kids
with emotional and psychological
difficulties and the city covers the
entire tuition bill of a hundred and
thirty eight thousand dollars per year I
guarantee you there are other kids
sitting in some of these warehouse
schools who would benefit from being in
the same environment my daughter's in
although it works out well for the
minority of parents able to sue the city
simply can't afford to send every
learning disabled kid to private school
at an average cost of fifty five
thousand dollars per pupil it is
draining hundreds of millions of dollars
from classrooms that desperately need
those resources to better serve the kids
they have when Eric Nadel Stern served
as the second highest ranking education
official under former Mayor Michael
Bloomberg the city fought back against
families suing for private school
tuition
we've got 1.1 million kids in 1,800
schools and part of the reason they're
not being well served this were
significantly under resource and
diverting the resources in a way that
benefits a few it's not a solution to
the problem this is not an option that
parents are just happily deciding to do
they're doing it because they really
feel that their child needs us Alexandra
Hin DES is an attorney at the Law
Offices of Neel Rosenberg a firm that
handles about a thousand cases a year of
this sort she says that if the system
did a better job of educating kids with
special needs her clients would gladly
send their kids to public schools I've
been doing this for about 15 years and
I've seen the Department of Education
reorganize their their offices their
committee is I think three times at this
point and there hasn't really been
significant changes in their programming
that would bring parents back to the
system but the process of suing is out
of reach for most poor families required
ability to navigate this legal maze of
stuff what do people do don't have
access to the high-powered lawyers and
the
the fancy neuropsych on Park Avenue and
all of this the biggest obstacle for
poor families is that the process often
involves fronting the money for private
school tuition while waiting for the
lawsuit to be settled or judicata
Bernstein had to front about forty
thousand dollars before the city started
reimbursing him had to be borrowed and
scraped together from pennies in the
couch I mean it was really it's it's an
incredible hardship and if you don't
even have you know you think most people
don't even have the ability to raise
1/10 of that kind of money
suing school districts to pay for
private school for learning disabled
kids happens all over the country and
it's a practice that's been affirmed by
Supreme Court decisions in cases
originating in Burlington Massachusetts
Florence South Carolina and Forest Grove
Oregon but it's a deeply flawed system
the question is how to provide poor
families the same quality services
without bankrupting municipalities one
approach would be simply to give parents
the money for private school without
requiring that they sue they're
currently 13 states with special
education voucher programs some of which
based the amount students receive on the
severity of their disability charter
schools are another solution I did not
know that we had an option to file some
type of a legal suit to put her in
private school our goal was always you
just have to get a school that can meet
Rachel's needs this week bill my wife
mentioned that to me I was like wow I
didn't know that every morning Rachel
Charlton and her parents make the
45-minute drive from the Bronx to
democracy pathways a charter school
program in Harlem that serves middle
school kids with learning disabilities
for Rachel whose learning challenges
stem from the fact that she was born at
just 23 weeks the school has had an
enormous ly positive impact we had a kid
that just didn't believe in herself
struggling with self confidence and just
feeling like she wasn't worth it and not
good enough and stupid because we
actually had people call her that dumb
and stupid and all these things to a kid
that is soaring high Mohammed how are
you nice to see you today sucks
a mission of the school is to build
executive functioning skills and to
create a sense of urgency
Duncan shares the program's founder an
executive director
they come into school dysregulated they
come into school feeling unsuccessful
and our job is to provide an atmosphere
that's predictable for them that's
filled with the routines that support
their learning considering that they're
coming in many years behind grade level
well private vouchers are nassima to new
york's progressive political
establishment the city already has a
robust charter school movement and
there's currently a push within the
sector to better serve learning disabled
students we're not working with students
who need us the most
then I don't think we're fulfilling our
promise you use up first edge they're
lacking at this point basic reading
skills that should have been developed
for most students at a first second
grade level oh no you're ready when your
posture is perfect and you are ready to
begin it's unacceptable to say that we
don't know that a kids struggling or we
don't know why there's not a ton of
debate over what to do with a kid who is
dyslexic so all my math key right I'm
gonna draw that same a squiggly bowl of
pasta sharer says the city's top private
schools serve as a model those are
amazing schools but their practices are
replicable which is something I think
we're doing here at pathways and at a
price point where these services can
more realistically be offered at scale
and not just to kids lucky enough to
come from families with the wherewithal
to sue per pupil spending at democracy
prep pathways last year was about
$34,000 for roughly 40% less than what
the city is spending to send the average
learning disabled student to private
school people will always say it's a
lack of resources there's not enough
resources within the system I don't
believe that that's true I think it's an
issue of expectations and I think it's
an issue of the quality of instruction
that students are receiving
I'm not gonna say that I don't think
like any private institution would be
able to deliver what the pathways has
delivered but what I've seen is
tremendous whether it's through the real
estate market or through hiring
top-notch lawyers and consultants
middle-class parents have always managed
to get great options for their kids but
the school choice movement is all about
is extending the same privilege to
everybody else
[Music]